let's go next to our caller from the 801
area code who's calling from 801 today
hi David this is John hey John Salt Lake
City what's going on and I had a
question about the Democratic primary
sure yeah it's cursed given that Harris
Warren and Buddha Jack Buddha just seem
to be vying for the same demographic or
the same voters yep I'm wondering if in
some sense there will be a ceiling for
them and those voters I see them maybe
it's like middle-class suburban college
educated and I think this ties in with
an earlier question you know that
another color Y which I thank you for
correct on but I think there might be
something in addition to what your
response was in other words Biden and
Sanders even though ideologically
they're very different I think they both
for different reasons appeal to
working-class voters I don't know if
that's the case for Harris Warren or
Buddha judge to the same extent yeah
that's interesting so if I understand
your question is will Harris Warren and
Buddha judge by virtue of sort of
competing for a similar slice of the
electorate will they hit a ceiling that
will preclude them from actually
securing the nomination exactly is there
a sort of zero-sum game for those three
as long as they stay in in the race and
they all stay strong well I don't know
that that analysis apply I mean it's all
zero-sum in that there's some number of
votes that will be the number of ballots
that will be cast in the Democratic
primary and it's in a sense it's all
zero-sum the question is I think whether
there are particular candidates that are
going to cannibalize votes from each
other from a certain electorate in a way
that will end up kind of be having a
spoiler effect and letting someone like
for example buy it and end up with the
nomination I think the answer is no and
here's why before any votes are cast
we're going to have a bunch more debates
a whole bunch of people are going to
drop out there I can't imagine that when
the first caucus starts in Iowa you are
going to have Buddha judge Harris Warren
Biden Sanders and did you mention one
other I think
actually okay so you me you actually may
still have all five of them but here's
the thing you know the the I think that
the polling even before any ballots are
cast is going to consolidate around
certain candidates in Iowa you need 15%
to get any delegates anyway so even if
you have like a five-way split not all
five of them are likely to end up with
delegates so I actually am not worried
about this I think it's gonna work
itself out on its own is if the deep my
concern is the DNC shouldn't put its
finger on the scales
let's have debates let's let's figure it
out yeah yeah totally agree
yeah the only I think what I was getting
at was that that might be an advantage
for Sanders because if Biden drops and
it seems like there's a good case to be
made for that yeah that Sanders would
pick up working-class voters and not
necessarily Terrence warden Buddha judge
who would be buying for more
middle-class educated voters that's
actually so interestingly about that
when Biden had his initial decline from
like 40-something percent in the polls
to like mid to hot mid mid 30s Bernie
was getting about 80% of Biden's decline
meaning like for every point Biden was
losing Bernie seemed to be getting at
eight tenths of a point and the other
two tenths were going to other people
but in the last few weeks
Biden's declines have been going more to
Elizabeth Warren to a certain degree
Pete Budaj edge and since the debates to
Kamala Harris so I think that generally
speaking you are right that Bernie would
be a big beneficiary of Biden dropping
particularly because lots of Biden
Reuters say their second choice is
Bernie but I think that the last 10 days
or so tell us that other candidates may
also gained from Biden's losses we'll
just have to wait and see yeah
appreciate your spot thank you yep thank
you for the call very very good to hear
from you and I hope to hear from you
again